yeah putting on the traffic hat now  heather anybody driving around the las  vegas motor speedway around sunrise the  next few days you won't be able to miss  the mass exodus of people leaving the  edc we're talking about three early  mornings three main roads affected by  the electric daisy carnival the northern  215 beltway the 15 and las vegas  boulevard the deal every morning at six  saturday and sunday but especially  monday morning thousands if not tens of  thousands of cars leaving the speedway  to get onto the 15 or the 215 and las  vegas boulevard monday again worse than  saturday or sunday but anybody traveling  in the area of the speedway watch out  for cars and pedestrians some folks may  be trying to walk away from the electric  daisy carnival going somewhere also  those ride share vehicles buses and  maybe keep an eye on the sky too heather  some people will be skipping all of that  and flying in and out of the speedway